Very common.
Sorry,
I'm a professor of psychology at Rutgers
University in Newark,
New Jersey.
Well,
it was an interesting research study by
events and Wagner that was done in 1975.
It was a long time ago,
but it was a very interesting study
where they,
they asked men and women to describe
their orgasms,
uh,
in writing.
And then they,
they remove all the specific references
to the genitals.
So you couldn't tell whether it was,
uh,
a man or a woman.
These were college students,
uh,
describing their orgasms.
And then they,
they,
uh,
gave the,
the descriptions.
Each one was about a short paragraph of
the description of,
of the orgasm they gave.
They gave the descriptions too.
Um,
uh,
sex therapists and,
and,
um,
uh,
various experts in sexuality and mds
and,
uh,
asking,
can you tell which one is written by a,
uh,
a male on which is written by a female?
And the upshot of the experiment was
that they couldn't tell the difference.
They couldn't identify accurately
whether the description of the orgasm
was made by a man or a woman.
Uh,
so on that basis,
my conclusion and their conclusion is
that,
uh,
the,
the feelings of orgasm when you remove
the specific reference to the genitals,
which would difference between the
genitals and the sexist,
uh,
that the feelings of the organism are
indistinguishable from each other for
between men and women.
Well,
we don't really know why some women
can't experience orgasms.
Um,
actually,
uh,
that was,
I started out by,
uh,
some years ago,
trying to find women who don't
experience Orgasms,
uh,
to study them in looking at their brain
activity during genital self
stimulation.
And we identified one woman and she,
uh,
but just before she came to our lab,
she said she got a new boyfriend and now
she's had her orgasm first orgasm.
So that,
uh,
that,
that did it for that experiment.
So,
uh,
we're still looking and it is a very
interesting question.
We don't,
we don't really know.
I mean,
certainly there are,
there are situations in which,
um,
with a peripheral nerve damage or
diabetes,
these can impede the neural transmission
descent,
the,
the sensory nerves as much more rare.
In the,
in the case of men,
um,
Kinsey,
uh,
reported that only,
a few,
uh,
two or three of the men that they
interviewed out of many hundreds,
uh,
could have orgasms by thought.
But,
uh,
we have found a substantial number of
women who can have orgasms just by
thinking and,
uh,
we've studied them and we're continuing
to study them.
It's really very interesting.
Uh,
the,
uh,
we have,
we measured their heart rate and blood
pressure and pain thresholds,
which is a pain thresholds go up during
orgasm.
In other words,
women,
we found that women become much less
sensitive to pain during orgasm and also
the pupils dilate and all those
measures,
the heart rate,
blood pressure,
pain thresholds and pupil dilation,
they all about doubled during orgasm,
generated by,
uh,
genital self stimulation.
What we've found is that women,
we had 10 women in the laboratory who
said that they could have orgasms just
by thought.
And we measured their physiological
responses when they applied a genital
self stimulation,
actual physical stimulation.
And then we compared it with when they
said that they had orgasms by thought
alone,
and the physiological responses were
essentially the same.
There were,
there were indistinguishable.
In other words,
they,
those women were really having orgasms
just by thinking.
And,
um,
there were,
they had different ideas.
We asked them what,
what they,
uh,
what their thought process is to elicit
the orgasm.
And some said that they had erotic
imagery,
but others said that they had,
um,
uh,
pastor al imagery,
like walking along the shore on a,
on a warm summer day.
Um,
other women had a much more abstract
image such as,
uh,
imagining the,
energy,
uh,
moving up and down their bodies.
The shocker is moving up and down the
bodies,
um,
and,
and producing the orgasm.
So,
uh,
they're a big individual differences.
And now we're looking at their brain
activity in a women who,
uh,
have orgasms by thought alone.
And we're seeing very,
a great similarities between when they
have orgasms by just thinking and
orgasms when they,
uh,
do,
genital self stimulation.
We're starting to study men and,
uh,
it's a very good question,
but we don't really know what,
uh,
what the differences,
it seems to be much more rare in men
than in women.
Uh,
one,
one of the things that,
um,
uh,
we'd be,
we'll be looking for is,
uh,
one of the things we're finding a really
very new findings is that when,
uh,
when women think of different parts of
their body,
uh,
the,
thinking about those parts of the body
activates the,
the sensory cortex.
Uh,
there's a,
there's a map of the body on the sensory
cortex.
In other words,
is the,
the fingers are in one place and the
toes are represented in another place.
The face is represented in another
place,
the genitals in another place.
Um,
and it's all systematically laid out
very much like the body.
The body plan is laid out on the,
on the sensory cortex.
And what we're finding is that when
women think about their finger being
stimulated,
or they think,
think about their toe being stimulated,
or they think about their,
their,
uh,
clutter is being stimulated or the
nipple that,
uh,
the,
the corresponding part of the body,
uh,
in the,
the,
the representation of,
in the sensory cortex of those body
parts is actually activated just as if
they're really being stimulated
physically.
Uh,
so I think one of the interesting
questions is whether since women can
think their genital,
uh,
systems into actual physical,
into actual activity in the brain,
can men do the same thing?
If they can't,
then that might be a way of
understanding why women can have orgasms
by thought alone.
Are they activating their genital sis,
their genital sensory representation,
which then spreads to other parts of the
brain and can mend,
not do that or we don't really know,
but we have the tools to investigate
that.
That's an interesting,
interesting that you asked that question
because we're really dealing with that
right now.
Uh,
because we have a,
a,
um,
we want to see,
since we know that if you think about
your,
think about the clearest.
So think about the,
uh,
the g spot.
We'll think about the cervix that those,
that the,
the corresponding part of the bottom of
the brain map for those parts of the
body,
those become activated.
So,
uh,
one question is whether a women who can
think themselves to orgasm,
do they think their genital activation,
the brain,
a representation of the Genitalia into
act,
into activity,
and does that spread to the other
systems that are involved in orgasm?
How do they do it?
We want to understand how they do it
normally.
And then the question is,
what if we,
uh,
ask women to think about the Janet the
genitals,
um,
more intensively or will we,
will we,
will they be able to intensify the
response in their genital sensory
cortex?
And will that spread to other parts of
the brain?
Will that facilitate their orgasm?
I'd be,
I think it could be very useful in,
in women who say that they don't
experience orgasms.
It could be a useful in women with
spinal cord injury who can't feel their,
their external genitals.
Can they,
can they think their a brain greater
activation and will that facilitate
their orgasm?
That's a,
it's a,
um,
it's a question that we are currently
dealing with it without a brain research
and it's a,
it's a very important and interesting
question and it could be therapeutic for
therapeutically useful.
One of the techniques that we're,
that we've developed is to have the
women in the scanner,
uh,
looking at their own brain activity in
near real time.
Uh,
and the question is if we can see our
own brain activity in near real time in
specific regions,
can we voluntarily increase the activity
of that part of the brain?
Just by thinking about it?
Uh,
just as um,
as we can think about moving our finger
and we can,
we can move our finger.
We can wiggle a finger.
We don't know what we do.
Uh,
we,
we learned to do it as an infant cause
we got the feedback between what we see
and what we,
what we do.
Maybe we can do the same thing with the
brain.
If we see our own brain activity,
uh,
maybe we can make a change and maybe
that's going to change the way we feel
or the way we move.
Uh,
so this is a,
uh,
a new technology of near real time brain
imaging and,
uh,
with,
unlimited,
uh,
frontiers.
We don't really know how,
uh,
how far we can go with that,
but it's a,
it's a new,
it's a new approach.